hello everyone welcome to part two on
how to achieve seamless operations with
gke load balancing please check out the
link in the description below for part
one of this video series that talks
about gke load balancers and the
different load balancing options
available for gke clusters the content
creators for this video are ashwaria
Rajiv and Shaquille Ahmed Siddiqui who
are technical account managers for
Google Cloud Consulting
they are specialized in Google
kubernetes engine and networking
this video covers the best practices for
setting up load balancers Health
checking and pod lifecycle and load
balancers to be used for cluster node
operations
so let's get started
after choosing the right gke load
balancer for your needs the next step
would be to understand the best
practices to configure either a layer 4
or layer 7 load balancer
the first best practice to set up a
layer 7 load balancer is to keep the
container native load balancing on which
is configured by default
container native load balancer is a
great way to get started with layer 7
load balancing on gke it's easy to use
and provides good performance and
reliability and hence there is no need
to disable it unless you have a specific
reason to do so
next Google will not infer the correct
health check for your https Services
hence you will have to describe it with
a back-end config using Ingress or gcp
back-end policy with Gateway
container native load balancer uses the
health checks you define in your Ingress
or Gateway resources to determine
whether your pods are healthy and able
to serve traffic if you don't Define any
health checks container native load
balancer will use a default health check
however the default health check is not
always accurate or comprehensive hence
it is best to Define your own health
checks to ensure your pods are only
exposed to traffic when they are healthy
if you need to have advanced traffic
management capabilities or more managed
certificates while using layer 7 load
balancers use Gateway API Gateway API
supports the most up-to-date https load
balancers Gateway API is a more powerful
API than Ingress and it supports
Advanced traffic management features
such as Canary releases and more managed
certificates than Ingress
the first best practice for a layer 4
load balancer is to use a gke load
balancer controller use gke subsetting
for layer 4 internal load balancers
however it is not available by default
for layer 4 load balancers and must be
used as an add-on
next use Regional backend Services which
require an annotation instead of Target
pool
Regional load balancers are more
scalable and resilient than zonal load
balancers
use a local external traffic policy only
when you need to preserve the client IP
use Standalone Network endpoint group
plus load balancer if you need a layer 4
proxy load balancer to use Standalone
Network endpoint groups plus load
balancer create a network endpoint group
and Associate it with a load balancer
let us now look at some best practices
that need to be followed while serving
applications using load balancers
while creating external and internal
applications make sure you use the right
load balancer type and set the options
correctly use container native load
balancing and appropriate gke resources
health checks and back-end services for
efficient handling of https traffic both
internally and externally
moving on it's important to understand
that there are particular sequences of
events that occur when pods are created
and destroyed
the state of a pod and its contained
applications is determined by a variety
of signals that will tell the gke
platform when and when not to serve
traffic to a pod instance
this has Downstream implications on
whether traffic reaches a healthy and
ready pod and can directly impact the
user experience let's now learn about
the entire pod lifecycle and the
different health checks that can be
configured
like individual application containers
pods are considered relatively ephemeral
rather than durable when a user or
controller such as an auto scaler
initiates the creation of a pod that
belongs to a service controllers react
independently to the event in the
following ways
as seen kubelet flow marked in green
dotted lines where the kubelet watches
the API server for pod resources
endpoint controller flow marked in
yellow dotted lines where the endpoint
controller watches for pods matching
service label selectors when a matching
pod is ready it's added as an endpoint
to a service the controller modifies
endpoint resources in the API server
Network endpoint group controller flow
marked in red dotted lines which
monitors the API server for pod
endpoints and service resources
pods May shut down for a variety of
reasons shutdown can be initiated by the
pods controller scaling down updating an
image or through failure pod node Etc
when the kublet receives notification of
the pods termination it starts the
shutdown sequence when the envoy
controller receives notification of the
Pod termination it removes the pod's IPS
endpoints to all the services that match
the Pod and the network endpoint group
controller leverage their own external
Google compute engine health check to
determine pod Health in gke there are
two types of health checks that are used
to determine the Readiness of pods
the gke Ingress controller uses
kubernetes liveness and Readiness probes
to determine the state of a pod behind a
load balancer the result influences the
Pod Readiness which indicates to
kubernetes whether pods must be
rescheduled
this probe also indirectly influences
the endpoints that appear in a network
and point group and to identify when a
container is ready to start accepting
traffic
Additionally you can use the Kube CTL
drain command to safely evict all of
your pods from a node and will respect
the Pod distribution budgets that you
have specified
to summarize load balancing and health
checks work together to seamlessly
distribute traffic
next let's explore the cluster node
operations and the best load balancer
type to be used for each case
there are four different scaling
operations available for the Clusters
being horizontal pod Auto scalar
vertical pod Auto scalar cluster
autoscaler and node Auto provisioning
horizontal pod Auto scaling HPA and
vertical pod Auto scaling vpa are two
different ways to scale your kubernetes
workloads
HPA automatically adds or removes pods
to a deployment or replication
controller based on CPU utilization vpa
automatically increases or decreases the
resources allocated to a pod based on
CPU utilization
cluster Auto scaler and node Auto
provisioning are kubernetes features
that can help you automatically scale
your kubernetes cluster cluster Auto
scaler automatically adds or removes
nodes from your cluster based on
resource demand node Auto provisioning
automatically creates new node pools
when needed
if we are looking to achieve load
balancer based Auto scaling we will need
to create a horizontal pod Auto scaling
object load balancer based Auto scaling
scales your pods based on the number of
requests received by a load balancer
this can be useful for applications that
experience spikes and traffic as you can
automatically add more pods to handle
the increased load the HPA object
specifies the desired number of PODS the
target metric and the scaling policy HPA
uses Target metrics to scale the number
of PODS the scaling policy specifies how
the HPA will scale the number of PODS
once you have created the HPA object
kubernetes will automatically scale the
number of pods in your deployment based
on the target metric and the scaling
policy
if you are using kubernetes we recommend
that you consider load balancer based
Auto scaling to improve the performance
scalability and reliability of your
applications
as we have seen previously gke's cluster
Auto scaler automatically resizes the
number of nodes in a node pool based on
demand this can increase availability
and control costs you specify a minimum
and maximum size and the rest is
automatic however workloads may
experience transient disruption during
Auto scalade
therefore to Target pods running on node
pools with cluster Auto scalar enabled
use container native load balancers
finally let's describe preemptable
virtual machines VMS and the kind of
load balancing to be used
preemptable VMS are priced lower than
standard VMS and provide no guarantee of
availability they offer similar
functionality to spot VMS but only lasts
up to 24 hours after creation
since there is no availability guarantee
it's recommended that you use container
native load balancing for back-end pods
running on preemptable nodes in addition
you can be more aggressive and configure
a load balancer health check to promptly
remove bad endpoints
you have reached the end of this video
we hope you found the content
informative and useful check out the
links in the description to learn more
about load balancing in gke or take some
Google Cloud skills boost Hands-On Labs
on load balancing happy cloud computing